now this week while we focused on the
growing tensions in america's major
cities
democratic party has been very busy just
as we predicted on the campaign trail
the left is now plotting to cement their
power in perpetuity
with a series of illicit moves next week
the house will vote on a plan for d.c
statehood i'm sure puerto rico to follow
and that would increase the democrats
majority in the senate
they're hoping ultimately with four
reliable
so they think so they believe democratic
senators
so they would maintain a senate majority
in perpetuity
now of course a the the plan would be to
have both puerto rico
and d.c but they're moving first with
d.c now
also that would be in probably no period
of time at all
a few days ago jerry nadler introduced a
bill to pack the u.s supreme court in a
proposal
that would add four new activist
justices there
now that would be a move that would ruin
the integrity and the function
of our judicial branch forever gerald
nadler is
brazenly lying and calling it unpacking
the supreme court
joe biden years ago said it was a
boneheaded idea then
it's a boneheaded idea now just like
democrats called their blue state
bailout a covert relief bill
that was a lie and just like democrats
referring to child
care and pre-k and a medicare
medicaid expansion and a massive tax
increase as
infrastructure everything now is
infrastructure they're even saying
packing the courts is infrastructure
naturally in order to get all of these
radical plans through congress democrats
are also working on a way
to abolish the legislative filibuster in
the senate
so we're watching what are statist
authoritarian measures
that are insane that would forever
change this country in ways
most people can't even imagine and by
the way
last year candidate joe biden flatly
told
we the american people that uh yeah he
supported none of these proposals
maybe he forgot he doesn't even even
seem to know what day of the week it is
take a look
speaking of those other candidates
several of them have proposed major
structural reforms to our government and
to our democracy these include
abolishing the electoral college
expanding the size of the supreme court
setting term limits for justices
abolishing the legislative filibuster
which if any of these do you support
none because that structural change
requires
constitutional amendments it grazes
problems that are more
damaging than the problems exist oh
that was only a year ago remember a few
decades ago
joe biden called packing court packing a
bonehead idea now
in the coming weeks we're going to see
if joe biden is even actually in charge
because he seems to be led by the most
radical
elements in his party the radical
socialists the squad seems to be in
control of
well pretty much everything so is he
going to stand by his decades-long
convictions
or will he change his position at the
drop of a hat
because he is governed by the radical
socialists i wonder
what will happen hmm the suspense is not
killing me
and by the way today vice president
harris welcomed
japan's prime minister to the white
house joe
that's your job where was joe biden nap
time
running a little long today and
meanwhile also today after the biden
administration announced
that it will keep the trump-era cap on
refugees congresswoman ocasio-cortez
she got rather unhinged tweeting quote
completely and utterly unacceptable
biden promised to welcome immigrants and
people voted for him based on that
promise
upholding the xenophobic and racist
policies of the trump administration
is flat out wrong now the biden
administration is attempting to clarify
their position
and they're promising to increase the
number of refugees in coming months
as i've been saying congresswoman
ocasio-cortez seems to be
the real leader of the democratic party
she certainly
runs the house nancy pelosi speaker in
name only
here with reaction former trump white
house senior adviser stephen miller
along with fox news contributor jason
chaffetz jason start with you
i never thought we'd see a major
political party go
this hard socialists left
but they did and they are now the
question is
will they and will they be successful in
packing the courts
ending the legislative filibuster will
they be successful in all of these power
grab efforts
uh i hope not they're trying to if they
can get past the filibuster then
all the other things start to roll from
packing the supreme court
uh to adding the dc statehood which i
think is constitutionally untenable
and those types of things but i do think
you're right you have puppeteers in the
white house
susan rice and other people that are
radical to the left
but the squad you look at what
congresswoman talib just said in the in
the last day or so where she said she
didn't
any law enforcement she obviously
doesn't want a southern border she
doesn't even believe there should be
incarceration and you have kamala harris
the vice president
who last summer was taking these people
that were writing
and and breaking the law and had
allegations of breaking the law
bailing him out of jail is just as quick
as she could so
if joe biden was supposedly going to
bring things back to the norm
into the center and work and be united i
haven't seen
one ounce of that coming up on close to
100 days in office now
stephen miller
what we're seeing right now is the
single greatest attempted
power grab in american history what the
left is doing is they're trying to use
this brief window where they're in power
to keep themselves and their policies in
power forever
that's why they're trying to add
democrat senate seats
that's why they're trying to end a
legislative filibuster that's why
they're trying to pack the supreme court
with radical left justices who will
abolish the right to bear arms
the right to free speech the right to
life and the right to even have a
sovereign country with borders
that's what's at stake sean right now in
all of this and you
mentioned it we saw today in the span of
but minutes
the by administration announced they
weren't going to raise the refugee cap
and then aoc says unacceptable change it
at once
and then joe biden salutes and says
absolutely
i will do as i'm told more refugees
coming to the usa
so aoc is running in the country not joe
biden
you know do you think that the u.s
senate now this is a situation where
kamala harris can't break a tie
you need at least one republican in a
50-50 senate
to create a quorum now can mitch
mcconnell keep the likes of
ben sasse lisa murkowski
mitt romney and others i'll ask you
jason because i'm sure mitt's a big good
friend of yours
yeah this is uh this you never know with
these folks
uh and that's the problem you just don't
absolutely know and you can't
rely on them to actually do it but it
will fundamentally change the way
everything works because steven's right
it's the biggest power grab we've ever
seen that's all they want
that's what hr one is about to try to
change the election laws and make them
federal federalize the election
to change the supreme court to add more
members anything to
be in power in perpetuity that's all
they want all right last 15 seconds
stephen miller
i think that this comes down to is this
question
can the senate republicans stand up
stick together
stay together to be the last line of
defense for american freedom
the fate of our country depends upon it
and it's what every american needs to be
paying attention to right now
as the byte administration ramps up its
attacks on american freedom
all right stephen miller jason chaffetz
thank you when we